[Music]
if stephen king
is the master of modern horror then h.p
lovecraft is the grand master
king himself has often cited lovecraft
as one of his biggest
influences and this becomes obvious the
more of stephen king's work that you
read
stephen king's dark tower series
obviously invokes many lovecraftian
elements
and i always point to the creature in
the book it a cosmic eldritch entity
that has the power to make people go
insane if they look into its true form
or stare into its dead lights
illuminating from the macroverse where
it originated
as you may well know lovecraftian horror
or cosmic horror is the branch of horror
that lovecraft
is known for it is based upon the idea
that our reality has an underlying
reality that is so strange
so alien that even glimpsing it would be
harmful to our fragile human minds
we as human beings like to think that we
can know
or understand anything
cosmic horror is experienced when we are
confronted by
phenomena that is beyond our
comprehension
and also when we are made to become
aware
of the fact that we are alone in a vast
and often malignant cosmos
[Music]
that's a pretty nihilistic idea but
that's also what makes it scary
now i've got countless lovecraft books
this one
is a book providing contacts on pretty
much every aspect
of lovecraft's life and work it's edited
by
leslie s clinger i think this book would
be an
excellent introduction to anyone that
wasn't familiar with lovecraft's work
and just wanted to have something to
reference so that everything made a
little bit more sense
right from the beginning so yeah i
thought this book was really good and
they've even got a quote from
one of my favorites neil gaiman on the
back of this
saying annotator leslie clinton is the
man you want to have by your side as you
explore the lovecraftian darkness
too true neil gaiman too true i also
have
many compilation lovecraft books and
stories
this one is one of my favorites it's
just the cthulu mythos
but the book is absolutely
beautiful i love the gold etchings and
it just has a really awesome feel to it
and the gold pages
on the edges it's really really nice so
it's just
all of the stories that relate to the
cthulhu mythos
the deep ones all of that's in here and
it's a really really nice book and i
keep it
on a nice place on my bookshelf and i
also have
this one which is also a collection of
the cthulhu mythos
and it's got these little phrases etched
on the front of it it says necronomicon
witch azathoth magic dunwich
so it's a collection of the cthulhu
mythos tales and it says on the back
the oldest and strongest emotion of
mankind is fear
and the oldest and strongest kind of
fear is the fear of the unknown
this one is nice to read because it's a
nice small
size so it's easier to handle than the
other book
and also i don't want to mess the other
one up so i tend to go
to this one when i just want to like
read a lovecraft cthulhu tale
real quick and i've also got this one
with a forward by
st joshi i really really like the green
coloring on this one it's got all of the
most famous short stories the call of
cthulhu
dreams in the witch house at the
mountains of madness shadow over in his
mouth
all of those stories are in there so you
could get this one and you would have a
nice
collection of lovecraft's most famous
short stories
this isn't my favorite one out of all of
them that i have
but i thought this would be a nice one
to show you guys
for beginners that want to just have a
book that has a good amount of stories
in it and then
there's of course this one the complete
fiction which i got at barnes noble for
shockingly cheap and no they are not
paying me to say that
but yeah so this is the complete fiction
it's just got all the stuff in there
it's in the back call of thulu mountains
of madness the done with horror color
out of space
it's got everything and it's got this
cool cosmic universe
madness design on the front of it that
looks really really cool and kind of
glows when you
turn it in the light so this one's
really heavy so i don't really like
reading this one because it kind of like
my hand gets heavy after time so
it looks nice on the shelf and that's
basically what it's for
now before i get to my favorite way to
read lovecraft
i want to show you two lovecraft
graphic novel adaptations the first
is this collection of stories
adapted by colbart now this is a
collection of i believe
four lovecraft stories there is the
dream quest of unknown kadath
the case of charles dexter ward at the
mountains of madness
and the shadow out of time the art in
the book
is is decent i think they could have
gone a little bit more scary with it
but the adaptations are very well done
and i think
this particular graphic novel adaptation
would be a nice one to pick up for
someone that has an easier time reading
a graphic novel versus
diving right into the really dense
really strangely
written work of lovecraft because he
uses weird words and he's just got a
strange
writing style that's kind of archaic at
this point
that's can be difficult to decipher at
times
so a graphic novel is an easier way to
ease yourself into the universe
now that being said though that graphic
novel
is really good the cold bird one i've
got a bone to pick
with dark tales now the dark tales the
call of cthulhu i know they have a few
other lovecraft stories that they've
adapted
so this was illustrated by dave shepard
and
it's just not very good at all the art
is not very good it's very basic
very bland totally not my style not
scary at all
not a match for lovecraft but also the
story is
really changed and all of the horror
that the short story invokes the
original short story
is lost this feels like it was made for
kids
and that's very bothersome for me don't
make lovecraft for kids
this was a complete fail i cannot
recommend
the dark tales to call of cthulhu
alright and now for my favorite way to
read
lovecraft the barringer fully
illustrated books now these books
are fantastic currently there's only two
available right now the call of cthulhu
and the first half of at the mountains
of madness
they take a long time to illustrate this
is really well done art
so reading the call of cthulhu this way
was so scary the art
is full page it pulls you right into the
story
every single page has unique art on it
and it is just phenomenal scary
i feel like i'm there with these
characters
experiencing the eldritch horrors seeing
what
they are seeing feeling what they are
feeling it is truly
impressive to sit down put on some
spooky music in the background
and open one of these up and enter into
this terrifying reality just for a
little bit
and then return back to the safety of my
library
so honestly i have to say i cannot
recommend the barringer fully
illustrated
lovecraft books i will buy
every single one of these that comes out
i am so excited for
the next part of at the mountains of
madness i am so excited for whatever
other lovecraft stories he adapts and
right now this is my favorite way to
read
lovecraft so with interest in the work
of lovecraft continuing to grow
and more and more lovecraft work being
adapted i'm gonna start covering more
and more lovecraft material on this
channel
as you may know i already have a backlog
of lovecraft videos
waiting for you including my video on
the call of cthulhu which i think is
probably one of my
best videos that i've ever done so
you guys can check that out if you want
more lovecraft content
and let me know what other lovecraft
stories you would like me to cover
in the comments section below and as
always guys
make sure you like and subscribe for
more quinn's ideas
hi guys it's quinn here i'm trying to
get to 30
000 followers on twitter in 2021
and you can totally help me out by go
into the link
in the description clicking on my
twitter page and hitting
follow and then you can see all of my
twitter antics
i'm always doing polls and rilling
people up
it's a different side of me that you
don't normally see on youtube
so yeah click that link in the
description it'll totally help me out
thanks so much guys